للمرة الثانية هذا العام ، صدر إنذار نادر من
صاروخ كوري شمالي في اليابان
بسبب صاروخ باليستي بعيد
المدى تم إطلاقه من بيونغ يانغ
ويختفي من الرادار قبل
وصوله إلى المجال الجوي الياباني مباشرةً ، وهو أحد
الصواريخ العديدة التي أطلقتها
كوريا الشمالية صباح الخميس بالتوقيت المحلي ،
ربما للتوضيح.  قدرتها التكتيكية على
الضربات النووية ضد
كوريا الجنوبية واليابان وغوام
في كوريا الجنوبية حيث
غالبًا ما تبدو التهديدات النووية الكورية الشمالية
وكأنها ضوضاء في الخلفية.
اقترب صاروخ بشكل خطير
من الجزيرة التي عبرت
خط الحد الشمالي ، وهي منطقة بحرية عازلة بحكم الواقع
بين كوريا الشمالية
وبيونغ يانغ الجنوبية ولم تعترف رسميًا
بهذا الخط حتى يوم الأربعاء ولم
يطلقوا صاروخًا فوقه ، سواء كان
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي يون سوك يو
متمسكًا بصقوره.  الموقف من كوريا الشمالية الذي
وصف الإطلاق بأنه فعال
لقد أغضب هذا الغزو الإقليمي بالفعل من المياه الإقليمية لكوريا الجنوبية
[تصفيق]
لقد أثار غضب كوريا الشمالية هذا الأسبوع
للمضي قدمًا في عملية Vigilant ،
وهي أكبر تدريبات جوية عسكرية مشتركة في كوريا الجنوبية
مع الولايات المتحدة لمدة خمسة
أيام من الألعاب الحربية 240 طائرة الآلاف
من أفراد الخدمة  من كلا البلدين ،
وعدت وزارة خارجية بيونغ يانغ
بإجراءات متابعة قوية
لشبه الجزيرة الكورية ، وهو يوم من الأوائل المثير
للقلق لأول مرة
أطلقت فيها كوريا الشمالية 23 صاروخًا على الأقل في
يوم واحد مما أدى إلى تصاعد التوترات إلى
مستويات غير مسبوقة خلال نصف عقد
في المرة الأولى التي أطلقت فيها كوريا الجنوبية و  ردت الولايات المتحدة
بإطلاق صواريخ أرض -
جو بالقرب من المياه الإقليمية لكوريا الشمالية ،
تحصي CNN 30 حدثًا لإطلاق صاروخ كوري شمالي
هذا العام بما في ذلك
وابل غير مسبوق من
اليابان هذا الأسبوع يدين بشدة عمليات الإطلاق الأخيرة التي
وصفت الهجوم الخاطف بأنه غير
مقبول تمامًا انتهاك قرارات مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة بشكل
غير
مسبوق.  توكي عالي التردد
احتجاج O الرسمي عبر القنوات الدبلوماسية
في بكين ، يبدو أنه لم يلق
آذانًا صاغية ، تتمتع الصين وروسيا بحق النقض في
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة في حالة عدم مزاج
للعمل مع الغرب على معاقبة
بيونغ يانغ لأنها تعزز
تحالفهما الاستبدادي
مما أثار مخاوف كوريا الشمالية في سابع
تجربة نووية تحت الأرض.  يمكن أن يكون
القادم ريبلي سي إن إن سيول